fifteen seconds to play one Russell a
triple for D'Angelo Russell Brooklyn 102
and the Pistons 110 point six seconds
left Russell come yesterday
and although have a nice comeback they
fell short as well much like the next
inside gets the three as the shot clock
expires to look good start now I'm gonna
go into the chest of home one on the
shot clock
Russell that's it fly rattles it in
you've saved so many stars like there's
a little disjoint in that in the last
minute and a half it's picked up again
Russell will try hands head he's feeling
it Dinwiddie the penetration and kick
crab ball fake Russell it's a three
what good ball with Russell pulls up
[Music]
Efrain Angelo Russell Russell picked up
by Kuzma Russell
[Applause]
ice in the veins D'Angelo Russell watch
and the Nets have been looking for this
switch and getting that and the Atkinson
calls out of play Russell with five
seconds high screen Davis Russell fire
up another splash
Bob Donovan she's reporter cord it was
late and it stands at home here feral
with the steal and a block by Russell
yogi Ferrell stuck with it and rims out
that Davis rips away the loose go home
as he walks the tightrope the effort by
D'Angelo Russell defensively he has to
be careful he drives in this is the ball
net to run up ahead Russell Skywalker
times it out pretty well too with the
shot clock
that's of attempted 34 threes still a
scrap and it's row Dion's look big in
ahead to Russell in time this year in
this building we've seen a lake zone
that litter a game around
[Applause]
you've got an excellent touch Emperor I
read an ATO is out of bounds I'm not
taking that back the law
so montrezl Harrell is dominated Jared
Allen inside so the 2-3 zone kind of
protects Allen from montrezl harrell
Russell looking for some stage fake
races a stop and go
oh no DeAngelo Russell is doing this in
a different level and a steal by Russell
Carol a three
[Applause]
D'Angelo Russell is the playoffs he gets
the bounce the end to the Russell up 18
points the juggernaut all season
tomorrow start to hit their stride and
then Boston and this Philadelphia team
you talk about it final chance with
Eastern Conference
[Applause]
it has just been a thoroughly dominant
performance in every aspects Billy
what's up you guys this Taylor Brooks
with bleacher report make sure that you
subscribe for some more video content